all right it's a tradition unlike any
other I think I mean I I can't quit him
I know that and here we are day after
the draft normally he would be calling
in kind to do that after working his
tail off on behalf of the NFL Network on
the draft coverage and now he is doing
this after working his tail off as the
man who shops for the groceries for the
Oakland Raiders the general manager mike
Mayock how are you Mike good morning
rich hey don't man I'm great so well was
it all you had thought it would be yeah
it was kind of all I thought and hoped
and even more and I think having have an
ownership having skin in the game takes
it to a different level I know and it's
it's it's a it was just amazing to see
also the reaction in all honesty to your
first draft choice in Farrell that if
you had been pounding the table for him
on the NFL Network for weeks and
somebody passed up on them they'd be
like why aren't they listening to Mae
Ock and then you actually do it as a
general manager and people are
questioning what you're thinking well I
I think every general managers every
pick is open to inspection it's the
world's biggest reality show right yeah
and now that I've gone over the dark
side it's open season on GM's man wow
that's a Star Wars reference Mike that's
a Star Wars reference right so let's get
into it
like a what are you a wonky or wookie r1
no it's a wookie it's a wookie but you
yeah I mean you were you were you were
you were chipping away at the edges of
that one okay what you like about feral
Cleveland feral that you chose him above
all the others that you could have had
right there yeah you know for us he's a
three down player and we felt like some
of the the top edge guys may not be
ready yet to set a physical edge and so
for as far as the football piece of it
he fits our scheme he's a three down
defensive end he sets a physical edge
and and he's got big sack production you
know if you want to take a shot at him
do you say
he has athletic if some of the other
kids maybe not he didn't run a forty
don't know what he ran at the end of the
day where we opened to moving down
knowing we could still get him
absolutely
but that didn't materialize but the
bottom line was we knew going in that he
was going to be our guy and whether it
was at four or seven eight ten whatever
he was gonna be our guy and we're
excited we got no I'm the flight out to
Nashville Mike I was watching the NFL
Network and and they were showing our
draft coverage from last year in Dallas
and the Browns are on the clock and I
throw to you and the first thing you say
is that you're looking forward to
hearing who this person is for many
reasons from the Browns but it's John
Dorothy's first pick as the general
manager there and as the first pick of a
general manager you need to set a tone
and then you you started describing what
that means for a first time general
manager and I as soon as I saw all you
know all the producers there that you
know so well I'm like we got to pull
that sound because this is this is mike
Mayock talking about what a general
manager is gonna do first time out and
you had that selection in ferrell how
has that kid fit that soliloquy that you
gave last year about a first-time GM set
in the stage he's 100% what I was
talking about a year ago a moment ago I
talked about him as a football player
but just as important if not more so is
the makeup of the kid and I think what
you're trying to do rich is two things
you're trying to be consistent
throughout the draft with the type of
kid you're bringing into the building
but that first pick for me as a new GM I
felt like it was important to set a tone
and Jon Gruden and I talked a lot about
this and you know since the day I walked
in the building John and I have talked
talked about foundation players and to
me foundation is defined as talent and
character and underneath character has
to be a high football passion a love of
the game and that's where Farrell stood
out on top of Cleland Farrell the
football player he's a leader he was one
of I think nine kids
his father had passed when he was 13
he had been through adversity when you
talk to the Clemson players that won
that national championship and we talked
to a bunch of them obviously yes we and
we asked who was the leader of that
defense every single guy said Clea
Farrell so the message we sent I think
to our own team was how important these
foundation guys are you better be you
better be a leader you better be great
in the locker room and you better be a
damn good football player well Mike we
had Josh Jacobs on a week ago and talked
to him about his story about living in
the back of a of a of a car and his dad
sitting in the front seat making sure
that nobody was gonna mess with the car
while the kids were sleeping and how he
had to put his film on Twitter to get
noticed and and he wasn't even so the so
called lead ball carrier in Alabama I
love that kid man I love him he's a
great story and again you talk about
adversity that's one of the things we
always talk about when we interview
these kids you know what have you been
through in your life and and how did you
handle it because it gives a little bit
of a precursor I believe to how they'll
handle adversity at the next level I
gotta be honest when I first got that
God took this job
the first player I took filming to sit
down with Jon Gruden who's Josh Jacobs
and I came back from the national
championship guy took the job and the
national championship game was in San
Francisco right so I I just got in the
car and drove over and was on the field
before the game watched the game I came
back the next morning watch the game
film I I pulled six or seven clips from
the game and I basically put him on the
computer system and went over and sat
with John I said listen you got to have
three minutes I'm going to show you
seven clips and we're going to draft
this guy that's how strongly I felt and
then again you you make reference to it
you took three you took three Clemson
Tigers and then Renfro is that kid too
who's who's come up big in big games
obviously what did you see in these
Clemson guys I mean why did you
obviously there may be an obvious answer
but I'll ask it anyway three Clemson
kids what attracted you and Gruden to
those kids well they're all they've all
played a bunch of big football games in
their collegiate careers they've all
competed at the highest level including
against Alabama for national
championships they've all they've
graduated their character is phenomenal
I think Dabo does a great job has really
turned that program and obviously in the
one of the top programs in the country
so it's a combination of things rich
it's a combination of watching the film
itself and evaluating the player it's
knowing what kind of program they came
out of which preaches accountability to
yourself your teammates your coaches and
your university and and then it's about
the adversity what they've been through
how they've dealt with it and at the end
of the day there better be some talent
there and we felt like they all had that
well a few more minutes left with
Raiders GM and my good buddy mike Mayock
you're in the Rich Eisen show and then
Mike your last draft choice I I ran out
of dimensions to describe how many
dimensions of chess you were playing to
to select Quintin Bell just as we are
playing stump the truck on the NFL
Network seventh-round draft coverage and
you'd you literally stumped the truck
with your draft choice by signaling it
did now did you did you did you get the
text just as you were picking Quentin
Bell I mean walk me through what you did
here yeah what happened was I didn't
even see the text from Charley uke I
don't know when he texted it okay but I
look down because when you're on the
clock you're just you're checking to see
you know the the trade calls come in
both via hardline and your cell phone
and I kind of looked down at my cell
phone I saw this text from Charley you
can I mean my first reaction was why the
hell would you keep me texting me while
I'm on the clock I want to knock him out
because he's in charge of our coverage
and wanted to still include you and well
in our in our game when you were
choosing a Prairie View kid I guess but
I mean at first I was like pissed I'm
like what you keep
I mean I'm gonna knock him out you know
and then my second thought is we're on
the clock so nobody can jump us I know
I'm taking the Prairie View kids so why
not accede to his request and and text
in the name Quinton Bell see if the
truck acid and your reaction was
practice I mean of all the moments for
us to be playing that and and you're on
the clock it was just the the draft
television gods were smiling upon us
Mike yes and you'd stump the truck we
did not have the video yeah I thought it
was really appropriate and on a lot of
different levels that's fantastic so the
last couple questions for you here Mike
before I let you go I do want to put you
back in the role for a brief bit of
draft analyst I ask you this every year
now being on as you said the dark side
the other side I'm wondering how you
answer the question of what part of the
draft
that you can tell from 60,000 feet that
the NFL has looked at these kids and
looked at the game today and decided in
a copycat league or just in the league
that is maybe transitioning into a type
of play what story does the drafting of
the prospects overall writ large tell
it's a changing game and rich you and I
have talked about it especially the last
two or three years especially with the
style of quarterback play and the style
of players were getting from college
football and the NFL is adapting and you
know you look at Kliff Kingsbury and
Steve time and the Arizona Cardinals and
they had a tough decision to make
and they went with the changing time so
5 foot 10 quarterback who's got special
ability and they believe that kids the
future of the NFL you know I sit here in
in my office and I look at this AFC West
wall that bases me every day because you
know were four and twelve and we weren't
very good last year and I look up at the
name Patrick mahomes every day and I get
pissed like like he's the future and how
do we stop them and he does things
nobody's ever done
and you know they've got guys that
spread the field horizontally and
Berkeley and so I think the games
changing we're getting different players
at a college football and I think the
theme continues that we have to evaluate
a little bit differently and that we
have to be more accepting of the type of
player that we're getting and did not
always say what can't the guy do but you
got to take a step back and say what can
this guy do to help us get better and
then you know being a draft analyst for
as long as you were with us we look at
drafts and we see who's been drafted and
say that this tells a story about a
certain team so as the general manager
does this draft of the Raiders tell the
story that Derrick cars you're a guy at
quarterback
well I mean we're always gonna do our
our homework at every position that's my
job right that's our job and I have a
head coach it loves quarterbacks so
we're always gonna analyze and evaluate
quarterbacks but you can meet their cars
our guy I don't think there's any doubt
about that and we're ready to ride with
him
fantastic hey man you've you've had it
all in your first couple months as GM I
mean you you acquire somebody of Antonio
Browns caliber just as all of that was
going on on social media you got your
first draft with three first-round draft
choices you got people second-guessing
your draft choices you had though what
was going on with the scouts which you
and I have talked about all fair and I
brought up on the air to what you were
doing with your due diligence on that
regard I mean you've been you've had it
all pretty much Mike
in the last blast I've never been more
energized Jon Gruden brings more energy
to every room he walks into than I've
ever seen in my life by anybody and and
all day every day it's about football
and finding the right people I might say
people I'm talking about coaches Scouts
players indeed it's all about the people
rich in every industry you know and
that's what I found whether it was
commercial real estate broadcasting or
the Oakland Raiders it's about the
people in the building and if you get
the right people together I think you
flourish normally after this you go to
Marion you know I'm assuming that
there's no Teton this time around no
there's no time
time you know there's a tinge of regret
but tinge of regret would be a great
fantasy football team named Mike if you
ever need one okay you're way more
clever than me okay you the man Mike
take care of yourself it's great seeing
Lee part of our broadcast team as well
this past time around is always good to
tell you you need to get off Twitter
oh she hurt tweets about you were just
spectacular I love it
take care yourself Mike that's mike
Mayock raiders GM here in the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app